hello everybody it's a little awkward that like you know the
very first gaming stream that i do is neo pets and not eight
pets look i don't know if you guys know but like neo pets
has been something i wanted to stream for like so very very
very very long
my god i can finally do it i can finally stream neopets also
apparently apparently this game um um the servers are now
very bad so most likely uh because i'm streaming neopets i
am going to clog up the server even more so that's a little
not reassuring for me so i hope that i'm actually like
explore this game by the way i have not played neopets in a
very very very very long time the last time i've touched
neopets was when they first introduced the neopets neopets
cash mall and then they like converted all the neopets into
like these dress up dolls so like um that's around the time
i sort of quit because like i at that i was like these are
they're ugly i was just like i was like oh man they're
pretty ugly now so like i lost my enjoyment of neopets but
also because another thing that happened also gabriel thank
you for the akasupa thank you thank you happy lunar new year
cheers from hk dragoons thank you um so another reason was
that um i lost uh my main account and i was like a
billionaire on my main account and I basically what happened
was that uh I my main account got hacked um but they not
only daily hack my main neopets account but they also what
they did was they hacked my email account associated with my
main account and then they used the email account to hack
other accounts because I got the email back and I saw other
accounts associated on my email and then I the thing was
because I saw other email other accounts on my account I was
so sad that my main account got hacked that I that I logged
into the other stolen accounts to try and steal their stuff
so I can cut some things back
I lost in my safety deposit box I had like like paint
brushes and like advent calendars from like so long ago you
don't understand and then so anyway I lost like everything
but my one unconverted pet which was a I don't know how to
pronounce it you know like those dark purple ones the
Deregans, like a Deregans, Deregans Lupe, and it was an
unconverted pet, and that was all that remains for me, for
my account value.
So anyway, after all of that happened, I, like, quit Neopets
because I, I, I was like, I lost everything.
I, I lost everything.
Why should I keep playing?
I don't have money anymore.
I don't have money.
I don't have, I'm nothing in my safety deposit box.
all my rare items are gone now by the way I also had had
like three other side accounts that was used as the lab ray
for those who don't know what the lab ray is it's big okay
I'm pretty sure I'm saying a lot of random words and a lot
of people don't know what I'm talking about because it's
like a lot of fucking random words and it's like jumbled up
together and they're like what the fuck is she saying
Oh my god.
Um, but anyway, there is like a lot of stuff.
Uh, uh, a lot of stuff going on.
Also, a little bit of a note.
For those who are, uh, wondering.
Um, all I will say is that, uh, would say is that I will put
up another statement um and later on because uh because I
believe there are some lies being told right now and I have
further evidence and proof later on so that is all I'm gonna
say regarding this uh regarding this if there is any
anything going on there will be a future statement being
published by me later on and that will further support my
evidence and um and if you guys hear anything there is a lot
of slander and a lot of lies going on right now um and that
I will be publishing a future statement in the future
regarding it which I have evidence and receipts as well as
backed up by my lawyer so that is all i will be saying
regarding any thing that's going on at the current time um
anyway anyway all i really want to do uh all i want to do is
that uh i want to just play neopets and and regarding a
document there was a signed legal there was a signed there
was a signed legal consent between me and the management
that it was just going to be between me, my lawyer, and
management.
But the fact that they released that to others is considered
illegal because that was not supposed to be seen by anyone
else.
And it was signed by me, my lawyer, and other lawyers.
Um, Um, so that is all I'm gonna say.
Uh, regarding everything.
Um, anyway, I can say this because my medical history and my
medical documents and everything that me, my lawyer, and
other people that were involved with, it was all signed and
agreed upon.
So, regarding this, um, it was very unfortunate.
that that was done.
Anyway, I do have more evidence and more receipts and more
statements later on.
Anyway, all I really want to do is play Neopets.
And nothing about that is going to stop me from playing
Neopets because Neopets brought me a lot of joy because that
document also has private information regarding me and
regarding...
Things that should never have been public to anybody else
But me and my lawyer So That is all I'll say Um Anyway Sorry
I had to make that statement because I believe That there
was another thing that was going on at the same time And And
that Uh And that I had to make that statement.
As someone else has been messaging me about these things.
And I really wanted to say that out right now.
But I will be making a further statement regarding this.
That my lawyer has written out for me.
And has been planning.
And we were planning on releasing it later.
But because of what's going on right now.
We will release it sooner than later now.
Yes, I really wished.
I was going to.
I really wanted to move on from all of this.
but and was going to move on and everything um and was never
going to address this anymore but because they've decided to
address it even though i wanted everything to be over with
um that is not my fault and because of this i will have to i
will have to um respond with um with a document and I have
written up just in case something like this did happen and
because of that I guess I will be releasing this document
very soon I prepared something just in case but I was going
to keep it quiet and keep it private and because that has
happened that has happened that means that I am now required
to release my story and release my statement um and i'm very
very saddened that my privacy was violated with this as this
document that they're saying was never supposed to be out
between other than between me and my lawyer and um and the
other lawyers so um we signed it and said that it was
supposed to be kept between us and the fact that they did
not keep that promise and the fact that they released it to
public.
And the fact that people that shouldn't have been reading
this read it and has my private information regarding it.
Um...
I was very unfortunate.
So I try to leave on very... On as good terms as I can.
Um...
So yeah.
I I'm very, it's very unfortunate that this happened while,
while I, I wanted to have a good first week.
And, um, and like I said, this is the only thing I would
say.
And, um, my lawyer and I will release the document that we
prepared, that we were preparing in case something like this
did happen.
Yep.
All right.
That's all I'll say.
Uh.
Anyway, anyway, let us, let us create our neoped, as we all
know.
I wanted to create a, I wanted to create a peturi.
I really wanted to create a peturi.
a Pateri also I'll also say that I've heard slander about me
behind the scenes and outright lies being told about me but
what they do not know is that I have receipts that this
proves a lot of things that were said about me behind the
scenes and it's very unfortunate that had to make that
public that will have to make it public like later on um yes
anyway so yes uh i really really wanted to uh
um i really really wanted to do uh do a beteri and because
it is i felt like that fits um that really and I think like
because of all of this happening I believe I will have to
talk to my lawyer after the stream so we're gonna keep this
stream very short but everything else will be on scheduled
everything else will be on scheduled from here and um and
for so tomorrow I'm still going to do the apex season launch
and everything else will be kept on schedule but
unfortunately unfortunately because of everything that's
going on I will have to talk to my lawyer and I want to talk
to my lawyer about all of this and finish up the document
that we have been working on.
So that's very unfortunate.
I really wanted to have a good first stream starting this
week but because of timing I really want to keep everything
private and really wanted to move on from here but it was
very unfortunate that all of this happened so I will try my
best to make up for you guys and we will try to have another
neopet stream in the future but for now let us just make the
tricoon i guess i really do thank all of you guys uh i
really do thank all of you guys for uh for being here and
for believing in me and everything um a lot uh i really do
appreciate it everybody um despite everything that has
happened it i was very sad to find out a personal document
that was only shown between three different parties had to
be uh leaked out um because it was a document i made for my
lawyer and it was a document that was not supposed to be
shown anywhere else.
But to me and my lawyer and to the lawyers on the other
side, and we were promised it was not to be shown anywhere
else.
So the fact that, and this was a document that was made that
was supposed to help me figure out what was going on between
me and my lawyer and to see if things that were happening
was actually happening.
And then we showed it to the other, the lawyers just to see,
to see if like they can figure out if what was going on was
actually happening.
And we were promised it was never going to show, be shown
anywhere else.
So the fact and the fact that this has happened really
messes me up because I have said that I felt a very lack of
trust for a while.
And I'm just left speechless that my trust has been broken
again regarding what I've thought was kept private.
That's really it.
And for a statement regarding all of this, I will talk to my
lawyer.
And we will be releasing another statement about this later
on.
Oh, all right.
Anyway.
Sorry.
I'm just happy that I just got a friend that messaged me.
I was just saying that they're there for me with all this
happening so it's really reassuring to know that my friends
are still there for me after all of this and uh and I'm just
really happy that like they're still there they're seeing
what's happening and you know what's going on and they're
still there through uh there to support me oh anyway um i'm
just gonna name we're just gonna it's really sad because i
was really looking forward to neopets i was really i was
really looking forward to neopets i was ready to move on
with everything um but yes uh Um, my lawyer is ready to talk
to me soon now, so...
My lawyer is ready to talk to me soon, so I'm gonna have to
call it here, guys.
I'm really sorry.
I'm really sorry with everything, so...
Um...
I'm sorry that I had to cut this short.
I was really looking forward to moving on and rebuilding
myself.
so um it is it's very unfortunate it really says a lot
though that people would try to bring down others when
people are ready to move on it really says a lot so i'm just
i'm just gonna call it here thank you everybody i'm sorry
that we couldn't really have and we couldn't really we
couldn't really have this neopet stream I was really looking
forward to it and I guess I'll see you guys later everybody
bye guys